what do you think of lizzo so I actually
recently did a video on this um I set up
Podcast but basically lizzo is
portraying something that is terrible
for young women and then you have
thousands of young women saying oh my
gosh those are so beautiful everyone
should be like lizzo and then you have
all the fat people looking at lizzo
feeding off of her positivity her body
positivity and why does she lead with it
too like to keep her brand like make
people sick yeah nobody would talk but
no Adele was overweight nobody really
spoke about her wait because she didn't
lead no you know they did speak about it
when she lost the weight right they were
like oh we can't believe you lost weight
we hate you now like we don't like you
like you did this for for social media
and it's like what yeah what about doing
this to save her life why aren't more
people supporting women losing weight
that's what real body positivity because